[Music]
people think
fat people never get off the couch
and people think that fat people sit
around eating all day
my mission is to challenge people's
assumptions about fat people
i'm mirna valerio and i'm a runner
i've been running long distance for
about eight years
i've done nine marathons
and ten ultra marathons with my longest
being 100k
[Music]
traditionally trail races and other
outdoor events have not always been
welcoming to people like me i'm black
i'm a woman and i'm fat
when i go to a race i know i'm breaking
the mold it's still very white and very
male so i know going in that i'm going
to be different
[Music]
all right 10 years ago i
lived a very stressful life and so that
took a huge toll on my health
i consulted with a doctor who
told me that i needed to change my
lifestyle pretty drastically if i wanted
to see my son grow up
so i did
i'd had some experiences with people
always making the assumption that
whatever i was doing it was for weight
loss after a couple of years it was not
a weight loss thing anymore it's about
fitness
running makes me feel
like
my most
human self
my first smile was pretty awful it was
painful
it was slow
when i'm feeling like this is really too
difficult i know that in the end i'm
doing it for a reason there's always a
larger reason
the end goal not always only being to
finish but the more important thing is
that i'm out there because sometimes i
come in last
it's amazing to me how many messages i
get on a daily basis saying thank you
for being you thank you for living in
your own space and taking up space and
not being afraid to do that because that
has allowed me to do that i'm going to
continue doing it because i think people
still need to see me
[Music]
you